[Music]
6 24 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about middle and junior
high school students building models of
the imaginary cities of the future that
could help solve problems of today using
engineering principles learned from
volunteer mentors i know that's a
mouthful but hang on there's more
those future cities are built using only
recycled household stuff and heaping
helpings of imagination to write and
memorize a seven-minute script like hyde
park middle school's seventh graders
josh vin and vish the first time she
ever created shall i press the button
yes you see josh and vin are from the
year 21-22 no way that's so cool you
guys came into a time machine who
stumble into our time why does the bay
look like a dumping ground that's
because the sewage from the industry is
flowing into the ocean we come from
waste is recycled and reused their
presentation takes fish back to the
future how do you do with all the
plastic produced in your speed well our
plastic is used in the infrastructure
and all the buildings along with diets
used in our roads and day-to-day items
like clothing students are judged not
only on their presentation and the model
of their city but also on essays
describing their solutions to some of
today's thorniest issues
josh vin and vish found out how they did
in a zoo meeting earlier this week
winner of the 2022
virtual nevada future city competition
is
xing
from hyde park middle school
so the team name is the name of their
model city and it was modeled after what
they think the future of beijing might
be now in the past a pandemic winners
got a trip to washington d.c for the
national competition but like a lot of
things during the pandemic that too is
going to be online this year but
congratulations not only to the hyde
park kids but to all the students in the
competition and their parents and their
teachers and administrators giving us
hope for a brighter future yay future
cities now if you know something that's
cool at school let us know cool at
school it's on the eight newsnow dot com
website under the community tab
organizes send us an email cool at
school 8newsnow.com